[Music]
so
do
[Music]
hey guys
how
i'm really happy that you're here if
you're visiting with us tonight a
special welcome
to you you are our honored guest
um
happy father's day to our dads stepdads
granddads uncles father figures moms
that are filling the role of dad
those for whom father's day is a little
complicated or hard just blessings on
all of you
and i also want to acknowledge that
today is juneteenth
and
marks the official end of slavery in
america and if you are not aware of
just the significance of june t
juneteenth for american history and
specifically the history in texas
i hope you will take some time to google
that look it up
learn about it it is important for all
of us to know about our american history
and our texas history
um
i have one announcement before we dive
into our service tonight and that is
save the date for our summerama kids
camp
that yeah
yes
no it's going to be here
yeah it'll be super fun lots of fun fun
stuff to do here so the dates for that
are august 5th and 6th i believe that's
a friday and saturday
so more information to come but please
if you have kiddos if you know people
even if they're not a part of the table
if you know kiddos that might like to be
a part of a really fun summer kids camp
uh let them know and we'll send out more
details as it gets a little closer all
right
so tonight is a very special night
around here we're doing some child
dedications
and
so without further ado why don't we take
some time to just land here
arrive you made it the hard part is
showing up sometimes so congratulations
you made it
take a deep breath
let your heart and body just settle into
the chair
close your eyes
and let's
pray
god thank you so much for tonight thank
you that you are here with us
thank you that you are with us in our
spirits in our very breath
and god
we give you our hearts
we give you our eyes ears help us to
just soak you in tonight
as we give you praise
as we give thanks for our kids and our
families and our parents god
just help us to trust you more and more
help us to hear your voice in all the
various ways
that um that you are present to us every
day
so god we thank you
and we thank you for all the ways that
you are in our lives working in us and
through us
in jesus name amen
will you guys stand with us we're going
to do a a song together before this
child dedication and for all you kids
who are in here i would invite y'all to
clap along with us there's a verse in
the bible that says even the rocks and
trees cry out and there's a part in this
song that says let the earth rejoice let
the rocks cry out let the trees resound
things like that and we want to join in
because we believe that even nature is
singing the praises of god of their
creator we're joining in with nature so
you guys can shout out in that part clap
your hands
um and let's actually worship with our
whole selves all right
[Music]
we dream of you
on city streets
breathing again on
[Music]
your glory feelings
we are children
of grace
[Music]
is
[Applause]
we dream of you
on country roads
strolling along with our friends
[Music]
leaving behind
flickering screams
[Music]
we are children
of grace
[Music]
rejoice
let the earth rejoice
at the seas
[Music]
let the rocks cry out
let the people sing their songs
[Music]
we are children
of grace
[Music]
is
oh
[Music]
let's rejoice
[Applause]
the rivers roads
[Music]
let the people sing this
arms rejoice
[Music]
let the people sing their songs
that was a fun one all right y'all can
go ahead and take a seat and those of
you who are involved in our child
dedication your parents and kiddos
um
others who will be praying can come up
um in a bit we'll we'll
have some words and things to say um so
yeah how about y'all come over here
oh and kids sorry i should mention hey
kids are staying in here for now
um
kids stay
we will dismiss you after this so hurry
y'all can come over here
all right all right all right yeah y'all
come up
all right
okay um so
it's i'm so excited about this this is
um
our first ever if i'm remembering
correctly i don't think we did not do
this pre-code but so this will be our
first ever
child dedication here at the table yeah
give it up
it's um
it's really really special so we have
got uh we've got nick here we've got
ethan
and these are this is the rolling family
rollins and then we've got phelan and
orly and rex and ash
i believe in in red and then opal over
there y'all pull in pull in close
um
so and actually y'all pull in as well
come in tight so then you all can be on
the camera people want to be able to see
yeah there we go
um
and
so for those unfamiliar child dedication
this is basically a commitment both for
the parents of these children to um make
a commitment just to raise their their
kiddos in um an atmosphere of um
christ-like love and discipleship and in
the context of christian community so
which i think is so important nowadays
when our culture we're so um i don't
know kind of splintered and separated
you know it's sort of like the nuclear
family is like
on its own adrift in the sea and maybe
they're lucky and like grandma and
grandpa live close you know but it just
um it's just it's rare that people have
extensive um support
so i think that's one reason and even if
you do i think it's just so important
that um also we have the context of
christian community like this is um so
this isn't just for parents and kids but
this is also for us
to say um we're committed to you
we want to love you both parents and
kids like we want to be there for you we
want to do everything we can to ensure
um that you all thrive
for years to come
right orley
yep
she says
so we'll just take that as a yes
um
and so uh what what i'd like us to do
is um there's gonna be a reading up on
the screen
and this is you can tell the language is
kind of geared for the parents towards
you know their children but um so much
of it applies to all of us in terms of
our own heart posture towards
the kids and these families that what
i'd like us to do is all of us read it
together so you know it says things like
my child and such like you get it don't
take it overly literally it's just us as
a community saying we're committed to
these children we love them we're for
them and we want to see god do great
things in their life so that sound good
yeah okay cool so uh let's go ahead and
put that um up on
the screen our reading
so you all go ahead and um read with me
i believe my child is a gift from god
and i endeavored to live this out with
my actions and my words
i commit to surround my child with an
atmosphere of unconditional love
and to guide them toward the ways of
jesus and the fruits of his spirit
i commit to be present and engaged even
when the journey is rough
i commit to pray for and with my child
when we are struggling or when we are
celebrating
i commit to listen when i would rather
yell
to speak the truth when it is
uncomfortable
and to be patient when i am tired
i will look for the good work god is
doing in my child and call it
i will do my best to be a living example
of christ transforming love and parent
from the values i see lived out in the
gospel
i realize parenting can be challenging
and i acknowledge my need for support
and encouragement from my church
i invite them along for the journey
we're going to do now is take some time
for prayer
so if you if some of these parents talk
to you about coming forward to pray with
them
for you to make your way um
and um for the rest of you what i'd like
us to do
is just offer up your own prayers you
know if you're comfortable with it you
can extend your hand towards them just
as a kind of outward sign of like hey
i'm for you i love you
and um
we'll take just a few minutes to to pray
and there'll also be some pictures on
the screen
these little ones so um in just a few
minutes i'll go ahead and pray and kind
of close out this time
[Music]
i pray
drawn towards your
[Music]
so
all right
let me go ahead and close this with a
prayer gracious god
giver of all life
we pray for these parents
give them wisdom and patience
let your peace and joy dwell in their
homes instruct them in your truth
strengthen them in faith sustain them
through prayer
order their lives by love
we pray for these children be gracious
to them draw them to yourself help them
to love and trust jesus
we pray that you will grow them in faith
that they might mature and represent you
well to the world
and i pray over this community may we be
strong
and in a stable context of love and
belonging
for each and every one of these kids
in the strong and powerful name of jesus
we pray
amen
go ahead and be seated
[Music]
all right kiddos you guys are released
to go to kids ministry
and if the rest of you want to stand
back up with us
[Music]
you unravel me
with a melody
you surround me
with
a song
of deliverance
[Music]
from my enemy
till all my fears
[Music]
and i am a child
i'm no longer
[Music]
and i am the child
of god
[Music]
from my mother's womb
you have chosen me
love has called my
and i've been born again
into your family
blood flows through
my veins
[Music]
and i am a child
of god
[Music]
let's sing that one more time together
let me go
[Music]
i'm a child of
of god
[Music]
so i could walk right through
you rescued me
[Music]
my ears
rescued
[Music]
the me
of
[Music]
and i'm god longer
safe to fear
[Music]
i
am a child
of god
[Music]
i am a child
of god
[Music]
thank you jesus
i love singing that song today in the
spirit of juneteenth
in the spirit of child dedication
um
just connecting with those words on a
different level where
he is the one who sets us free and he is
the one who calls us out of our fear
sets us on a rock like we were talking
about last sunday
and um
[Music]
if you are so bold can i get a show of
hands if anyone who really loves control
just anybody who likes that like me i
just
i love myself some control
it's just so comfortable isn't it
um
and that is you know my natural bent in
parenting
in relationships
it's so easy to just
take control because then you kind of
know what to expect you know at least
the best you can
but i feel like
god calls us to something more
to something beyond ourself and our
agenda
and we have an opportunity
to let him in
and see what he's up to in our lives in
the lives of our children or the lives
of our friends the lives of this church
community
and it's so hard sometimes to let go of
that control
so hard to let him come in and have his
way
and i was um
thinking about this next song it's
called make room
and
if we're actually going to say like god
i want to make room for you
that requires something from us cause
that doesn't happen by accident like you
don't accidentally make room for
something you know what i mean like
if i walk into my closet and i'm like i
need to make some room
i can't just stand there and wait for it
to happen like i have to declutter i
have to get rid of stuff right i need
to simplify
and sometimes to make room for god
that's going to require some
intentionality on my part it's going to
require a little bit of release of
control some trust
some space with him where i'm listening
i'm asking him what he's up to what he
wants to do
so i just want to challenge us as we
walk into this next song
what is it that we need to remove
what is it that we need to let go of
so that we can make space for what god
wants to do
his ways
and if we really believe what scripture
says that his ways are better than ours
then it's going to require some
intentionality
it's going to require some work on our
part to walk that out
so i just want us to be pondering that
as we sing this next song together
ask god what what is it that he's asking
us
to let go of
[Music]
here is
this is my surrender
here
[Music]
can you guys sing that with me
this is my surrender
here is where i lay it down
every lie and every dog
this is my surrender
[Music]
to do whatever you want
to do
to do whatever
[Music]
[Applause]
let's lay it down
here is where i lay it down
every bird in every crown
this is my surrender
here is
[Music]
to do whatever you want
to do
[Music]
whatever you want to
to do whatever you want to let's think
that
[Music]
do whatever again want to
do
[Music]
to do whatever you want
to do
[Music]
tradition break down
tradition break
down of all my religions
[Music]
break down
is
[Music]
i will make room for you
to do whatever you want
to do
come and have your eyes
god whatever it is in our life
that our
fists are grabbing so tightly onto
would you give us the courage
to loosen the grip
whatever decisions are being guided by
fear
would you bring in peace
and would you help us to trust you
[Music]
whatever actions
that we're making out of a sense of
control
god would we look to you and allow you
to soften our hearts
and show us your ways
will we make space
in our lives
for the ways of the kingdom
one that's full of freedom
and grace
one that's full of redemption
and love
god would we have soil that's ready to
receive all of that
and would we foster it would we help it
to grow
thank you god for your good work that
you do in us
continue it to completion god
it's in your name that we pray
amen you guys can go ahead and turn to
the people around you and
greet them welcome them and then brett
will come up and um and we'll get seated
and start our message
well good evening
grace and peace
my name is brett and it's super good to
be with you all
i um
i also wanted to um welcome those join
us online as always you are not
forgotten we love you a lot and as well
as anyone here um who might be new thank
you for um
being with us
it's really um it's such a special day
between the dedications i love that
it's such a gift to have children among
us you know um yes they're loud and
crazy and i live with i live with seven
so i i know um and you all know we hear
them over there often you know um
especially like last week probably maybe
today too when they can't go outside
because of you know all the heat so we
hear like yelling but um but it's good
it's good it's a blessing to have them
and um
i also wanted to to
echo karen in wishing you all uh all
those dads out there happy father's day
and uh and happy juneteenth um such a
yeah special special um
day
so tonight
we are kind of continuing on in our
series that we started last week um this
series is titled hearing god a listening
life
and um
what we um kind of the the way we
defined hearing god you know like what
is what does that mean cause this is
sort of a phrase that's often thrown
around you know in church circles like
well the lord was talking to me the
other day you know if you're like kind
of an outsider that's just sort of like
what like god you're literally just like
eating your breakfast like you're you
know you're oatmeal or whatever and
god's like well hello there you know
like oh my gosh you know what is this
going on
and then people feel guilty or
on the outside looking in right because
they're like god doesn't talk to me like
that oh gosh well i guess not what do i
do or maybe i just i'll be silent or
i'll fake it if need be you're like oh
yeah the good lord he was speaking to me
too you know um so
so i went last week i kind of defined i
gave kind of a definition of hearing god
and it's this hearing god is the
metaphor christians have used down to
the centuries
to describe the way that god through the
holy spirit is continually teaching
guiding instructing and leading us from
the depths of our own
being in other words um
i use language of metaphor not because
like you're saying it's fake it's not
real like no it's um
because when when we use the phrase
hearing god people can think it's like
literally audible
and
that's possible i mean my goodness god
can do whatever god wants um but that is
of course like the exception rather than
the rule you know god this is a rare
instance where god's like literally
audibly speaking to people um
so that's why i use language of metaphor
because we say hearing god and god
speaking to me um it's it can be you
know audibly it can be and the loud and
the extraordinary the miraculous and the
breakthrough and you know all the things
it can be that way um but in terms of
you know jesus talked about praying for
our daily bread you know the daily bread
of hearing god is not necessarily like
always you know the awesome the
breakthrough that you know it's it's
often it's this this is what mostly what
christians are talking about
right it's like it's um this sense of of
god speaking um through the holy spirit
within so
uh with that in mind the the title of my
message specific to tonight is hearing
god in scripture what i want to do over
the next few weeks is kind of dive into
like more specific ways we hear god um
you know in scripture um through kind of
emotion and feeling um and through
community and others so that's kind of
where we'll be going but tonight is um
scripture so our our text is psalm 119
verses 15 through 16 and the psalmist
she says this i meditate on your
precepts
and consider your ways i delight in your
decrees i will not neglect your word
so so here's my big idea for tonight
christians desperately need to
rediscover scripture
as um as the place where god speaks
to us personally
um not just in general because i think a
lot of christians oh yes the lord he
speaks you know through the scripture
and
in general you know gives us truths and
such you know in an abstract way but
like no no that's not quite what i'm
getting now although that's true too but
like we really need to discover as the
place where god is speaking like to us
um
and now you ask kind of okay well how
what would we do different how would how
would that work
and i i think the way it's it's the
shift we need is to um
start to approach
the text in in a way that might actually
be unfamiliar for many of us but much
more in a posture of um
prayer
and
meditation contemplation
uh
as opposed to a mode
of um
kind of analysis
and study
you know where we are like okay i have
got to be in the scriptures more i'm a
christian christian should read the
bible christians should study the bible
we should like get all i should know
this stuff and so i've got to get in
there and i've like got to start
figuring out or read the bible in a year
or like get through i gotta like i gotta
understand this stuff now um
you'll kind of hear throughout the
message i'm not necessarily saying
that's like bad you know we're like oh
don't never study the bible you know nah
that's not quite my point um
i have spent
some might argue far too much money
learning to study the bible
it pains me a little bit to see
tens
of thousands of dollars in the years um
so you know
you know i don't think anyone would
if they know me if they know even kind
of the table and how we are i don't
think people would be like the table is
totally anti-intellectual you know that
brett he's just you know always dumbing
it down so much no not so much if
anything of the problems maybe a little
the other way where i'm like you know
every other message losing people you
know so like that's the challenge so i
mean i'm not saying don't study don't
think hard don't read theology don't ask
questions don't do any history or like
i'm not saying that but but as we'll get
to later that has its place um
but we've got to start we've got to
start here
we've gotta we've got to rediscover the
scripture as a place where like we can
get quiet and god can actually like say
a word to us speak again not audit i'm
not saying like you hear the booming
right i'm just in in the depths of our
being where we just we have a sense like
oh my gosh that was like fresh
for me
that spoke to me that resonated with me
um
we might say it like this
spend a little less time
reading the bible
and
let god use the scriptures to read you
to speak to the deep places within you
know that might sound like i'm just
playing with words you know but um
there's again there's a difference
between
kind of approaching the text like a bit
of a scientist
you know or an academic a historian a
scholar of religion you know and uh
in that kind of scholarly mode that has
this place but again it gets us kind of
removed
from the thing you know what i mean it's
sort of like there's a bible and i'm
kind of here like hmm
not sure what to think about you you
know i mean like we're in that kind of
that's like a totally different mode
than when we're in that more prayerful
more contemplative um
letting the bible read us our own hearts
and minds um
so
i don't want to get like too much into
like with weeds in history of why this
is but somebody said to say i think some
of the why
is because you know for us like if
anything's 100 years old it might as
well be forever you know if any
tradition
is 200 years old it's like oh my gosh
eternity it's always been like this you
know and i think that's kind of what's
happened to us um you know to make a
long historical story very short uh
there's something called the the capital
e enlightenment you know that kind of
burst upon the western world started in
europe made its way to america and you
know it's the rise of i mean honestly
it's the rise of the world around you it
is it's the rise of science
and you know the scientific method and
analysis
and um
and kind of data
and you're like this it's just the whole
kind of mode i mean that's just very you
know it's a very western you might not
realize this until you get into a
different culture
and it's just different you know like
we're just wanting to like
analyze the problem
analyze the thing you know and other
people or it's like more poetic more
it's like there's i know there's just a
different kind of mode and i think
what's happened is that kind of that
objective kind of uh if you're trekkie
you know it's a spock spock not a spock
it's spock it's that you know he's kind
of the the analyzer and the i am i'm i'm
doing data and computations you know
it's almost the human like computer you
know i mean almost like that's the ideal
human it's like a good computer and the
ideal bible reader is someone with vast
knowledge
who can just know all the things and
like you know unpack it and that's sort
of like we got to study the bible you
know what i mean like even how people
approach it like you got to get in the
scriptures yeah i know i need to do more
bible study
and that interesting like that's just
our default like that's what it means
what else would you want me to do study
it
um again nothing that's bad but it's
it's interesting our language
you know because if by study you mean i
just need to sit with this text let god
speak to me
and approach it very much in a posture
of prayer if that's what you mean by
study well then by all means proceed you
know
but if it's like i've got to pull these
pronouns apart you know and get back to
the original language like the people
often have this idea if i could just
learn the original languages then i'd
know the bible like oh my gosh no it
just pushes the problem back further
like no
no
we've yeah um
so kind of what i'm really advocating
for is a we might call a little bit more
pre-modern approach to the bible this
would be like people christians before
300 years ago
i think this is um
a little bit more naturally how they
might have approached the scriptures in
other words ancient christians came to
scripture seeking a word from god not
just information about god
and that's where i think it's
interesting in more modern times
we've tended um to
again kind of approach it um
well kind of approach the scriptures in
a way where we've we've sort of
understood the bible as like an
encyclopedia
of god facts
you know and it's like i you know or
objective you know clear truths
principles for living
you know it's like like some sort of
manual it's the christian the manual a
user's manual
full of bullet points and like and then
you actually have you read the bible you
know what i mean it's like
in i mean it's amused i don't mean this
in a bad way i mean insane like crazy
like remarkable poetic i mean there's
poetry literature
letters some sort of apocalyptic end
times thing the book of revelation
there's like kind of some sort of play
like in job there's the psalms proverb i
mean it's sort of i mean it's
it's remarkable
right but that's not like the clear
scientific user's manual to the
christian life
you know like it's just it's just not
that's not what it is
and i think this has kind of messed us
up
see i think um we've approached the
bible more like a riddle to be solved
rather than the story of christ a story
in which we
make sense of our own story so in short
we've got to start to approach the bible
more like someone in love and less like
someone working on their phd
now um how do we do this
i think
what um what ancient christians
understood was there's kind of two ways
two levels you might say to approach the
bible the first is um the literal
level
the literal level this describes the
meaning of scripture in its original
historical and theological context
and um of course you know history the
original meaning this is
again super important
um
but it's not all there is and and the
reason is because i just i know so many
christians
um
either and it kind of comes it's
interesting it can be both kind of
theological very conservative folks
and theological very progressive folks
you know but both are sort of
approaching the bible in a very modern
way like on the one hand you'll have
conservatives who are like kind of
reading it as a kind of as god's user
manual you know as the answer book for
everything you know
um almost like a scientific treatise or
something
or a philosophical treatise and then
over here you have kind of more
progressive christians who are like
picking it apart from a historical
critical perspective like doing all the
work behind the text oh that's not
really talking about that that's
actually talking about this other stuff
right and it's it's sort of um
but it's interesting both are kind of
playing the same game you might say
whether they're approaching it at the
literal level
um even kind of biblical skeptics like
folks who are not at all you know
christians um also tend to approach the
text at this literal level let me give
an example um for example like a
biblical i don't know someone who's
maybe more skeptical might say something
like um evolutionary theory
it's correct like obviously
therefore genesis chapters one through
four right this whole creation narrative
and such this is just like freaking
silliness this is just like pre-modern
outdated
embarrassing stuff in the bible you know
it's like it's dumb right
um
now a more kind of modern um christian
might respond by saying oh no you don't
oh no you don't
the bible that is science that is
literal history everything happened and
uh and so you can see where they're sort
of fighting each other right they
disagree about the interpretation but in
essence they're sort of playing the same
game can you see that like they're both
kind of approaching the text as this
like manual of
i don't know everything science and
philosophy and whatever
um and i think this is a somewhat
sterile approach to the bible
so after a lecture one day there was a
theologian
named carl bart
and
a man i've
read far too many pages of
he's he wrote his systematic theology
his i don't know how many volumes so
many volumes so many pages
and uh and so he's i mean he was a
brilliant brilliant guy but he was
giving a lecture
and a woman
at the end there's some q a you know so
she asked him
is it true
that the serpent really spoke
now i'm not actually sure where she was
coming from i don't know was she like
more of a skeptic who's kind of like
that is so this is the just typical
biblical ridiculousness and i'm gonna
prove this theologian thinks he's so
smart you know he believes serpents talk
you know i don't know if she's coming
from that perspective or i don't know if
she's like maybe on the more
conservative side and kind of testing
him do you really believe the bible you
have all your words and all your
systematic theology and all you know but
are you a true believer you know i'm not
sure which way she was coming from
but it's sort of one of those trap
questions you know did the serpent
really speak this by the way just for
those unfamiliars genesis 3 right
there's that moment where the serpent is
tempting eve
and says did god really say
you can't eat from any tree in the
garden oh
oh god knows if you do
if you eat
you will be like him
knowing good and evil
so it's it's an interesting little story
so she's kind of asking did that really
happen
is that true
do you believe that's true and he had
the most brilliant response he said he
said this said madam
it does not matter whether or not the
serpent really spoke all that matters is
what the serpent said
that's really sharp now um
this i think this is a fascinating
answer because what's what's he what's
he doing well i think actually this is a
good example of the second level
he's i think he's trying to raise her
vision
raise her eyes this is what we might
call or what ancient christians call the
spiritual
level
the spiritual level of scripture
describes the meaning of scripture as it
points to christ and illuminates my own
heart and mind you see when carl bart
said the question is not
did the serpent really speak that did
that snake really have vocal cords that
could do that and you know
when he said it's not that it's what did
the serpent say
he's naming that scripture it through
the spirit it becomes the word of god to
us
when we approach the bible not as
scientists and not as scholars
not as people who are um somehow in
control who are going to determine what
really happened or not or you know
whatever but
but when we read the text well in
essence when we allow the text to read
us
right when we ask a question like this
um when was the last time
that serpent-like thoughts
went through my head
like that's the way to read the bible
right this is where i just i have no i'm
just not into those that level of debate
at that little level like well did you
really think that could happen or not or
i just don't get it like no we come to
the text of scripture and we trust that
god has a word for us
that he's speaking something to us that
he's challenging us that he's calling us
higher
i'm not angry i'm just passionate
i'm
right this is this is how we read the
bible we don't get in there like now
again actually i say this isn't how we
read the book that's an overstatement we
can you can get in that mode i think
kind of what you find is once you engage
the spiritual level once you can come to
the text scripture with a sense of not
just trying to pick it apart you know
but in a kind of air of openness i do
think you get level one back again i do
think you're able to kind of return
and do some of that without feeling
quite so anxious you know because when
all you have is the literal level you
tend to get at least if you're christian
and prison many of you here are right
you get there's a certain defensiveness
at times like oh gosh i gotta you know
instead of realizing like relax relax
relax
scripture is scripture because it's the
place where
generations of christians have found god
speaking in in through these texts
right it's it's that moment when we
read this
genesis 3 and we hear the serpent's
words and we ask ourselves what kind of
serpent-like thoughts have been going
through my head
have i been questioning
the goodness of god just like eve did in
that moment you know is god really good
because i i'm just worried i'm worried
he's holding out on me
like that's
that's the way to read the bible and
that's what ancient christians called a
spiritual reading a spiritual approach
to the text i want to come back to our
passage psalm 119 notice the language
here i meditate on your precepts and
consider your ways i delight in your
decrees i will not neglect your word
can you hear the language now in that
right um
i meditate i consider
i delight
delight
i mean can you hear the difference
between i study analyze and objectively
come discern to discern the truths of
the holy scriptures you know i mean like
that's such a different
mode than i consider god i meditate on
it i reflect on it i take it in
i let your word read me
and you do your thing
and it changes and transforms me
that's such a that's like such a
different
mode of engaging the scriptures and i'll
be honest i think people um i i hope
this message is hitting home especially
for those of you who have been through a
season of deconstruction or maybe find
yourself still in the midst of that you
know because a lot of deconstruction
tends to happen at that literal level
and that's well and good that's again
i'm not saying like there's no place for
that there's church you're like no no we
can ask hard questions of the bible we
can do that um but also
it's so important to rediscover the
bible as the place where god speaks and
to find the scriptures on the other side
of deconstruction because deconstruction
is very much happening at that level one
that is i mean pretty much
all of it you know um because that's a
totally different question what did the
serpent really speak as opposed to what
did the serpent say and what is god
saying to me and that can you see how
that's like not really about
deconstruction or something that's
that's something deeply um personal so
this is now this is how i approach um
the scriptures on a like a day-to-day
basis this is how i prepare sermons is
in a very similar mode i'll do some
level one for sure
mostly
mostly level two
you know mostly like it's mostly i come
to the scriptures and i read it and i
ask god like god what are you saying
to me
what are you saying to our community
what's your word for us
um you might think of it as the
difference between you know um
a bird watcher
and whatever the term for a scientist
who studies birds is
you know like someone who um
ornithologist is that a thing i'm just
saying that that just oh my gosh just
came to me the brain is so weird i want
to thought right and i'm guessing an
orthologist does some dissection
you know i mean you want to study the
bird well the way to study a bird is cut
it up you know and that's sort of level
one that's sort of how a lot of
christians like you want to understand
this text dice it to pieces you know
instead of well to understand birds and
maybe watch the bird
see how it lives like and the upside is
it stays alive
you know and that's
that's kind of us for the bible we've
just torn it to peace into shreds and
it's sort of laying there bleeding you
know we're like i knew there was there
was nothing good here
you know i mean it's like well you kind
of sliced it up you didn't um
didn't discern the form you didn't
discern what the spirit of god was up to
because this has resonated with
hundreds of millions of people for
thousands of years you know maybe we
should be careful before we just kind of
slice it up and discard you know i mean
yeah so in closing i want to do kind of
a little bit of application i want to
give you some steps so you're like okay
so tomorrow morning or tonight how do i
actually do this um step one uh quiet
yourself
right step one uh quiet yourself so that
means grab a cup of coffee
favorite cup of tea whatever you do
get in a quiet place maybe go outside
not right now
stay inside
and just quiet yourself step two
read a passage of scripture one to four
times
this is where it's interesting to read a
text repeatedly as opposed to like well
i'm trying to get through a lot here you
know got to get through my chapter or my
five pages or my whatever your bible
reading plan is you know there's
something about approaching smaller
chunks
and reading a few times third um notice
which word or phrase connects with you
resonates with you
um
this is um this third step this is this
is really the key
right seeing the word scene the phrase
because this is the moment where i trust
the holy spirit like god is speaking
right you're my people even have a a
phrase for this like that's that that
word it just jumped off the page at me
christians have said this for years i've
heard this you know and it's that's kind
of the moment you know what i mean and
not that it's always like dramatic and
it just
you know but it's just something in you
will be drawn
you know
so see what stands out to you
and then step four reflect on how this
word or phrase calls you to deeper love
trust and transformation in other words
just ask god why that word why that
phrase god what are you doing
what are you doing in or what are you
speaking to me
and and
what do you want to change and transform
about my life
um
so that's that that i think can you
imagine if we as a community actually
started to do this you know like
rediscover scripture
as not just god's bible answer book or
something but but as
the way he speaks a fresh word to us i
just i think that would be beautiful
so as we um come to the table
tonight
um
this also this
practice of communion this is a place
where god speaks
and so in the same way we don't need to
necessarily come
you know analyzing
i don't know
anxious worried what does this mean and
what is this
i don't understand you know how is
christ in the bread and the cup you know
it's just like okay calm down and just
open yourself to god's spirit it's just
a moment this is why we call it
communion
connection
right and that's that's what this time
is about so as you come forward to
partake of the bread um which symbolizes
the body of christ as you take in the
wine which symbolizes his blood may i
mean that's my prayer for you is that it
is just a moment of deep connection
so this is the table
not of the church
but of the lord
and it's made ready for those who love
him and for those who want to love him
more so come
you who have much faith
and you who have little
you who have been here often and you who
have not been here long
you who have tried to follow and you who
have failed
come
because it's the lord jesus himself who
invites you
and it's his will that those who want to
meet him should meet him here
come to the table
[Music]
so
do
[Music]
so
do
[Music]
so um
i shared this the other day in group
um and uh basically you know if you ever
had that moment maybe you haven't this
is like an anchor moment with god you
just feel like
[Music]
you felt this love his presence his
redemption his forgiveness
um quickly i'll i'll tell the story you
know i'm i'm from i was in the navy i
was at the time pretty steeped into
alcohol and
um even drugs and
like prostitution was a thing like
um you know being a part taking part of
that and after i became a christian
there was a lot of shame and guilt
around that area of my life and
later on as as i walked out what it
meant to be a christian i
found myself
on a mission trip to india in a
situation where i was in a room with
women who were safe from prostitution
and
the leader of the trip asked me to
lead us in worship and sing amazing
grace and in that moment as i sang
i just felt the waves of
of redemption and forgiveness and grace
just knowing that
you don't have to carry that guilt
around anymore
you know um
so i don't know if you've experienced
that or not or something like that but
um
it's there for you
god's love is there for you and um
yeah just thought today
[Music]
i wanna know
some laying down
[Music]
all my religions
i used to think
[Music]
i'm laying
i'm laying down
[Music]
is
can separate
us
reach
[Music]
say no amount of untruths
find me
[Music]
see no amount of untruths
can separate
[Music]
i will rejoice
in the simple gospel
i will read yours
[Music]
yours
i
[Music]
say no amount of untrue
i will read yours
in the simple gospel
i will rejoice
thank you so much for being here tonight
i really hope that
something in the service just touched
you right in your heart
if you're visiting with us tonight we
would love to connect with you beyond
this evening we have some little cards
out on the table right as you go out the
door to your right if you could just put
your name and contact information drop
that in the box and we'll get in touch
with you this week
um
don't forget about the kids camp
summerama happening august 5th and 6th
and then if you could all rise to your
feet i would love to send you out into
your week with a benediction that i
believe is true
for every single one of you
you are a child of god
you
are a child of god
this is true on your best day
and it's especially true on your worst
days so as you go out into your week
ahead with its yet to be determined
highs and lows and everything in between
go with the assurance that you are loved
you are worthy
and you are accepted just as you are
and go filled with god's holy spirit and
the desire to extend these same gifts of
grace
compassion and unconditional love to
everyone you come in contact with
be blessed
have a good night and we hope to see you
back here next sunday
[Music]
you